It's kind of fall so today we will be reviewing the pumpkin spice latte.
America's long tradition of combining sugar and artificial flavors.
Oh, yea. Super orange.
The aroma you really do get nutmeg.
And I love nutmeg. It might be a prison drug, but I don't look down on it.
I thin you could actually use this as a pumpkin spice creamer.
In other coffee as well.
You know if you let these guys sit for a while, grease kind of coagulates on top.
It's kind of like a pumpkin spice lava lamp. I don't know if that's an advertise feature.
It's pretty good, I can see how you can kind of hooked on these.
As far as coffee goes, that flavor is pretty much gone.
We're just getting a lot of, a lot of good sugar and milk.
Not that there's anything wrong with that... MMMM.
This guy gets a good three stars. And it kind of leaves my tongue desperate for air.
or at least not sugar.
I could be bitter about this lack of coffee but that would be a silly expectation
This is it, they really jumped the shark here. Because as a pumpkin spice latte
but it's iced, if it was actually cold would I really want like a giant iced drink to cool off?
You know it doesn't quite, it doesn't quite make sense.
You know these spice flavors are funny, it's like they're just almost there
but they're kind of missing something
A real spice might kind of get in your nose a little, it might kind of give you a tickling sensation.
I think this one kind of cheats because it really improves as it waters down.
You really can taste the coffee better in the iced one.
Which I think is strangely ironic. So as long as you're comfortable being you know a post-modern individual
I think this is the winner, so we're giving it four stars.
but you know the latte as we drink it the sort of build-your-own monstrosities that copies become
is totally like an American invention
an in that sense there's really nothing wrong with it. There's nothing that says that coffee needs to be this kind of European thing where it's always
always served in small glasses and things like that
You know, if people want... In America you can definitely do whatever you want.
And that includes what coffee beverage you choose.